live great
yeah nice to meet you atlas
yeah i've been chatting for quite some
time and look have been looking forward
to this
meet you bro
so great to get into like the topic of
micro dosing and what it can do for us
in this
global awakening
and yeah i
contacted you or
suggested this topic because of um
my
intuition
is that it is more accessible to people
that have not yet had like a
full-on
awakening experience with insurgents and
so
my first question to you
would be like
what has your experience been so far
with like the different
dosages or
was the from ranging from like
a true micro dose to like a
real
full-on
and theogenic release experience
yeah dope
yeah i love your channel conscious
development it's great bro
for all for those that are watching that
haven't checked it out you can find the
link in the bio it's great he just had
frank yang on it was such a good
conversation between i loved it yes
it was a great conversation
so good yeah and i'm glad that we got
linked up for this and i totally agree
with what you just suggested which is
that anthogens especially micro dosing
are in many ways exactly what
is
the tool that we can use to decrease
the separation conditioning that has
been accumulated over time
so in the dance of the one which is what
this reality is
that when we accumulate separation
conditioning it can be really hard to
unwind and soften ourselves back into
awakening or into remembering that this
is the one dancing with itself and that
you are that you are the entirety of it
and so
it's
how does one do self-inquiry or
types of meditations concentrations and
meditations in order to unwind said
separation conditioning um
much more difficult in many ways than it
is to just ingest a single gram of magic
mushrooms and then to and then to have
that experience which is um in many ways
just the decentralization
of one's identity
into
what is the field
that's it i mean really in essence like
you created
a um a boundary
and um
then you turned it into like a self for
many of us including myself in this
process we turn it in this boundary we
turn it into a self-referential system
over and over again which is i am a
separate person amongst other separate
people and that
everything becomes about that
self-referential process
typically things like uh i need to seek
happiness and peace and i'm going to do
that by accumulating external things
like experiences or relationships or
material possessions
substances this type of stuff
and
so then and that's all to try and heal
that illusion of separation conditioning
um nothing is ever separate and it's
never been separate and everybody is
already awake and everybody is already
the one and yet there's the appearance
of people being asleep which are people
that have forgotten themselves at the as
the one with the separation conditioning
so for me the process of just ingesting
a single gram of magic mushrooms which i
think is the most
simple micro dosing
entry point um so like a single half
gram or a single gram of magic mushrooms
um and it depends on many other things
like the strain it depends on the
concentration of psilocybin and cylosin
the psychoactive compounds that are
within it um but in generality speaking
um that's what i would recommend and
it's just a universalization or a
decentralization of your identity so
rather than that egoic self-referential
separation process you become the all
you recognize the all so you relax much
of the constrained neural circuitry
around your identity and you liberate
yourself into oh i am everything that is
what i am and i'm infinite and that's
what this shows me so that would be
my answer there
that's so great um
that actually
kind of refers to my own
entrance into like psychedelic
experiences
for myself it um
it was like nine years ago that i had
like the first magic mushroom
experiences
and it started like you said like
i
i was very
naive at that point i have to say as
well i didn't know much about
spirituality about what this
deeper understanding of
the world actually
can evolve into or how it can change
how you perceive this very moment
and so i started also kind of um
from the perspective of a full and
theogenic experience i started kind of
low
with this like half a gram or a gram
experience but then after
[Music]
two or three experiences of that i
quickly
increased to like two and then three
grams
and
just to give maybe people who haven't
had this kind of experience um a
perspective of what to expect
um
i would share my own experiences with
these different levels
because
when you don't have the
spiritual knowledge the background and
you don't know what to look for
in my experience it was not possible to
like dissolve this whole ego structure
with the first trips on the micro doses
or on the like let's say um
minor doses
it's not like a true micro dose would be
like in my understanding something you
can function on during your day like
maybe 0.1 or 0.2 grams where
you just do your normal regular stuff
but with like half a gram or a gram
the first trips they
were just colorful
nice experiences for me
but then after i had like the big
awakenings in trips
now
the same dose of half a gram or gram
is a completely different story
i don't know how is your experience with
like dosages depending on what your
level of
insight was when you think think back
now
uh has it also changed your sensitivity
to the substance
yeah that's a great insight so basically
if you take like a visualization where
you have like a hundred percent of your
separation conditioning that is in store
and in place
up here
and then you can say that that's like
being asleep and that over time the
awakening is just the eradication of the
separation conditioning down to zero
percent
um that antiogens the way that you could
see the way that they play is that if
you take like a half gram or a gram
let's say to start at a hundred percent
you might get exposed to very like clear
insight to the interconnectedness of
everything and then you might start
questioning your identity being separate
and so that shifted you from 100
separation conditioning maybe down to
like 95 or 90 separation conditioning
and then over time like you suggested
also you might increase your dosage
maybe to two grams or three grams of a
magic mushroom experience you might also
play a little bit with five more dmt or
lsd there's plenty of other substances
that are psychoactive that are
entheogenic to try and just quickly
would like to say entheogen means
unleashing god within or unleashing the
divine from within
so we're not talking about some sort of
a mystical experience that one attains
but we're talking about you recognizing
yourself as god as the one as infinity
and as all of this being that
dancing
and so
bringing it down over time with these
higher doses what happens is maybe
you're at like 75 percent separation
conditioning and you take a larger dose
well first of all you're gonna have like
you said all that insight that has
already compounded since you brought it
down from 100 to 75 percent and then
you're also going to have the larger
dose and the larger dose is going to
show you more
um
more
of
the dissolution of the ego structure
like you were also mentioning and so
um this is why they're very powerful
things and this is why um
whatever the 1960s or so counterculture
this is why that happened as well um
very powerful movement but then also the
powerful pendulum swing back with the
war on drugs um because you can't just
dissolve people's ego structures because
then there's not going to be
consumerists
and um people that are uh working at uh
corporations um
as um asleepingly as the economic
machinery and those that are in power um
would enjoy um so yeah so this is sort
of you could say like the
generality of it is the slow
unwinding and softening of the
separation conditioning from a hundred
percent to zero and um the way anthogens
can play into that they're very much
like um gateways or like um they're
they're good parts to the to the journey
of awakening i would say
yeah that mirrors my
experience um you mentioned there in the
beginning um
that we can also later talk about i
think is
that there are other substances like lsd
5m odmt
and in my own experience lately i've
also tried 2 cb
so let's keep that in the back of our
minds because i want would like to come
back to like the differences between
psychedelics later
because i find it it's also something
not to overlook um
because it's for me it's the flavor of
how the experience unfolds nice
um
okay then now we have like um your model
of like let's say you you we all
when we get to this let's say we start
at our own hundred percent
ego identification also important to
just say that not everybody because
given if your birth to like very
awakened parents
or if you're birthed into um like a
indigenous tribe that is very
interconnected with life
the
uh the separation conditioning it may
not even start at 100 it might not even
form in the first place because you have
to you have to remember that when you're
birth to asleep parents in a sleep
culture then it goes from zero percent
and it goes to a hundred percent when
you're like whatever 18 or 25 and then
you go and from your 25 until you're 30
and you're seeking or whatever to
decrease it back to zero so yeah that's
one way to look at it
okay so
some people will struggle more with this
than others
okay and also culturally there are
differences
like i think back or when i think of
india i would imagine there are more
people who have like who are not at 100
percent ego structure
oh nice oh cool so you might say like
generally
um
per person in the u.s there might be
more ego structure than per person in
india yeah cool yeah i would i would
guess like um because it also shows in
our like cultural behavior
like how much we are focused on
what we think is real like in the us in
the western world it's
our
perception that
objects have their own inherent reality
that manifests in our behavior
of
putting so much energy into
building all of that stuff and
accumulating it in our lives because it
gives us this feeling of
having something real
in our life because we have confused
that to be the case
um
yeah there's a lot of functions that are
tied into the self-referential ego
structure yes yeah yeah because you
mentioned that in the beginning it's
basically this
self-referential and self-reinforcing
cycle because only when you believe in
something to be real will you invest
energy into it
and so only when you see there is this
separation between you and what you
perceive
will you like
think that these things have some
inherent existence apart from
the whole flow of
yep
reality
um okay and so to come back to like this
um
initial
question of microdrosing and how it can
help us to see this
[Music]
inherent unity
of everything that is
how would you say it's like
would you say there's a difference
between
for example let's say someone is going
with
um
a micro dosing experience every week and
he does that for like 50 times
over the years or um or over a year and
compare that to someone who is going to
decide to like do
a 3 gram or even more
trip when we say
like let's say here with magic mushrooms
in your
or do you think there's a difference
between how those two paths will unfold
yeah um
i would also start by suggesting that
and i know frank talks about this quite
a bit as well but that
anthogens are like one of the main
tools on the belt but then there are
other tools on the belt like for example
concentration and meditation um
like vipassana is a great tool so is
just the normal like do nothing
meditation and like sort of um go beyond
the thinking mind um
yep into what is the space that allows
the arising and disappearing of the
thinking mind
um
and then see how that's the same um for
all of us like that space is the same
the i
is the same
before our name
um
and so contemplation is really important
like self-inquiry so self-inquiry
vipassana do nothing concentration
meditation
in in addition to anthogens so that way
it's like you're tackling awakening from
the many-sided mountain um and all of
those things are like compounding onto
each other in the process
um
and that's kind of what i did the last
like five years and that sort of helped
me a lot um
then in terms of like if you do end up
doing antiogens more frequently i mean
for me um it's been like every six
months or something um
yeah the last like five years
and um
and yeah i would say that that's a
pretty good um
like timeline uh
for
people that at least have already um
went through great um
insight into unity um because it you
know for people that have went through
great insight into unity it makes sense
to sort of like do it a little bit um at
a longer period of rest between um to
sort of let your new um insights sort of
further integrate um but if you're first
if you're like really really fresh and
you have no idea and you feel a lot of
separation conditioning um
yeah it could be good for you to maybe
do it once a month um to start um
like a half gram or a gram every month
to start now doing it every week is a
little bit
um you could do that i know people that
do that but you sort of also want to ask
yourself like
um
you know the intention is to integrate
what you learn
so
that's the key thing is like if you're
gonna feel
interconnectedness if you're gonna feel
oneness if you're gonna feel service to
others if you're gonna start feeling
that
um to take the week to take the month
instead of the week for you to actually
maybe do something with honor
in service to other people
in service to the whole
um
that that would
potentially
teach you another important lesson or
two or three in the three week break
normally then trying to compound it
every week
so that's just some of my take on it
yeah what about you
um
i agree with all that you just said um
because in my own journey it has also
unfolded in this like
slower process you could say or not
really forced process where
i gave myself the time to let my lift
reality catch up to
the inside that i had
and
it just feels so help so much healthier
in the beginning it was like more of a
kind of let's see how how deep this can
go and how many insights one can have
but then you come back and it's like
so much and you have to somehow
put it all in its right place and you
need just time to figure that out and
what you mentioned there was
the practices that's also
much of the emphasis of what i
do over on my channel
i mostly talk about these
practices and how you can have these
insights also
with contemplation with meditation
and here's really where i see them both
like micro dosing like true micro dosing
up to half a gram of mushrooms let's say
maybe even 0.1.2
where i see they really shine
is in the combination with meditation
and especially contemplation
because
compared to like a three gram trip where
there is no choice anymore you just have
to surrender
the smaller trips in my experience you
can also
use their power beautifully to direct to
certain questions or topics you want to
contemplate and really
um
[Music]
where one person would take like 1.1
gram and go about their day as usual and
get like really nothing spiritual out of
it
if you approach it with the right
mindset and go deep with it in
meditation
that combination i found is super
powerful
and
it
also
in my experience is able or it's
it's possible to do that on a weekly
basis
because it just takes your meditation
that little bit deeper and doesn't like
give you
material to work on for weeks
and um
yeah cool so it's all about the dosage
but would you say
at a certain point if someone only does
smaller doses they hit a certain plateau
or they cannot have deeper insights and
that maybe higher dose would be
necessary
yeah
totally totally it would be like for me
to say like why don't you go hike um
a mountain
um but um
let's say the mountain is uh you know
whatever three thousand meters
um
but i tell you uh
um only go uh 300 meters up the mountain
but then only go 300 meters up the
mountain again next week and then only
go 300 meters up the mountain again next
month and one year from now only go 500
meters up the mountain so you know you
kind of like feel into that um
in your own process
um
and
like
you're only going to see so far 300
meters up the mountain like you don't
see so far like when you look
um
when you look you're only going to see
so far but when you go 500 meters up
when you go 1000 meters up when you
start really going up
um
so when you start doing two three four
grams of magic mushrooms when you're
really starting to you know get up
almost to this heroic dose
um
you're seeing like the end of it you
know you're seeing the the last bit on
the mountain um
you're going the
um
the 3000 meters up but the thing about
um that is that it's like a gondola ride
the entheogen is like a gondola ride
because you go
um
and like uh magic mushrooms is like a
slower gondola ride then like 5-meo dmt
is a faster gondola ride so you're
you're taking this gondola up and then
you peak the top and then the gondola
goes back down
and so
what i'm suggesting with the analogy is
that um you want to wear
this like heroic dose or these larger
doses would take you after you sort of
build up the courage with the micro
doses and you start tasting more and
more of the one that you already are an
awakening to that that what you would
like to do is you would like to
re-baseline your identity your
conviction your realization
all of it you would like to re-baseline
that in your moment-to-moment direct
experience as the top of the mountain
without anthogens and that's where
contemplation meditation self-inquiry um
that's where all these things come into
play like you know when frank talks
about this he talks about it like
there's a contemplative
fitness
that ai that's just running all the time
um
and like that's sort of what it ends up
being like is like you just you run
as the entire universe you run as
infinity um and everything is just a
lesson for the individuation for its um
unique expression everything is seen as
just a school everything's seen as just
a lesson um everything's seen as just
one not like separate people telling me
um things but rather it's myself telling
myself um the thing that i need to know
for me to decrease my separation
conditioning and for me to feel more
oneness
and you see that same thing happening
with like the decentralization of the
banking and energy infrastructures
around the planet is it's a shift in
identity from separation conditioning
from centralization to planetary
collective awakening decentralization
so you
so the mountain analogy is important
here if you're going to take these micro
doses over periods of time you're only
going to go you know 300 meters up
repeatedly but then you do baby step
your way up to gain more insight of what
is seen from the mountain um and the
joke is that you know when you do get to
the top you were it the whole time um
that's the cosmic joke and it's
hilarious
yeah
yeah on that level that you were
speaking from um you also get the
insight
that when you take something or
when you take a psychedelic again
that it didn't even happen that it
doesn't even
that it's not a thing
you are not on a trip or not it's all
it's one thing and it's just there
it's just you could say an opportunity
for you to
see what is already there it's kind of
you allow yourself for that experience
to unfold but it's not
in the substance
there is no
psychedelic that is like doing that
apart from the flow of experience
which the psychedelic is a part of
yeah
one of one of the ways to visualize this
is that you're you're god with like a
stylist you know you're the painter
you're infinity you're the painter
um you're using your will and your
choice
and you're choosing you're willing the a
sleeping process
you're willing it you're building your
own you're with your own stylist but
you're not doing it consciously you're
doing it unconsciously or subconsciously
you've designed your own escape room
and people think that they're victims to
reality but they designed their own
escape room infinity designed its own
escape room for itself and then the
liberation like bentino bentino massaro
talks about this like a unfreezing of
will like you have all this will that's
frozen in these like subconscious
separation conditioning patterns
and what you're doing over time is
you're regaining you're unfreezing that
will and it's becoming more and more
liquid and more and more air-like and
you recognize yourself as this god
painter infinite stylist
and then
that's it like that's it like you feel
the
like the the vibration of what it is um
and that's your state that's that's your
new state of being without without
anything else that needs to i need to
ingest something or and nothing nothing
like that you just are it
moment-to-moment moment yeah
yeah that's such a beautiful description
um in my own experience it unfolded as
the
recognition that a psychedelic trip
is no different than my
regular state in the sense that is it is
all
my creation it is all my wish and even
the like you could say the confused date
before knowing myself as the oneness
is the same beauty it's the same
and that that gives so much peace you
know and it could also give to listeners
here
i feel
a sense of
yes you are on that path on that
spiritual unfoldment that is happening
through you
but it is at the same time perfectly
where you are
it is perfect to be in the place of
not knowing
of not perceiving what is
it is a paradox in the end but it is
still god's will to experience all parts
of itself and
to in order to do that it has to
confuse
itself
with a with a particular role
with the individual human absolutely
yeah that's just how
realities are created yep it's there's
no
you could even say it's the most
important feature of realities is the
ability to fall asleep and to wake up
yeah if it wasn't for that what would we
what would we be talking about
you know
you'd be yeah it'd be like it'd be like
if you landed in grand theft auto or
video game and you were immediately
level 100 with access to everything and
you started the game it wouldn't make
any sense no
yeah and that's also why um
why i feel micro dosing is so great and
it was
overemphasized i think in the 60s
to take
only the full release dose
i think it was also
then revealed in the
overall reaction of the society that
this
approach was maybe a bit too fast
as it was maybe for the individuals that
were
i can only imagine but many of them back
then without like proper knowledge in
the western
societies were challenged by these
insights more than they maybe could
handle
and bringing that kind of unreflected
experience into society
was only there or could only happen in
that backlash could only result in that
backlash of um
making all of these substances illegal
and
um so learning from that i think now as
you could say
i don't want to call that way but you
could see it as like the second
revolution of psychedelics i think we
have learned from that to go
slower
like on an individual basis but also as
a community to say okay for myself i
feel more comfortable
starting
low and then i give myself the time to
integrate really everything i experience
and i see this as a
five or 10 year or maybe even 20-year
journey
and i don't need to rush and
because as we just said it is
god's will to experience every
perspective and so
um there's nothing wrong with wherever
anybody is staying
standing in their understanding of
the whole of reality
yep and it's all you so the faster that
you remember that it's all you
that the more that you don't have
judgments about your other selves it
doesn't make any sense um
once you sort of wake up to that
it becomes
your
radiance of love and acceptance for the
entire creation exactly as it is because
there's still um
like you can feel it still in the
majority of the collective's um
energy is that um
i don't love and accept you because you
think differently than i do like that's
still like a very common way of being
especially like political parties um
and even it's seen in um
so basically seeing through i mean i was
gonna say like it's seen in like sports
as well like sports teams clashing like
it's seen and all this type of stuff um
but seeing through the separation is the
key to awakening but not um
seeing through it and then stopping
intellectually because that's a
different um
it's like basically being the mycelium
like that's another way to say it is
like you are the mycelium like you are
the field like underground there's
mycelial networks and
you are
them like you are the way that they in a
decentralized way talk to each other and
exchange resources with plants like you
are that
um
uh
and
you beca you are that you like you you
re you wake up to being that and not to
um
to being a separate person with
a non-love and a non-acceptance for the
rest of people that think differently
than you do so you recognize that you
are the all so just waking up to that is
like
i mean it's un it's yeah it's
incomprehensible because you also wonder
well i never fell asleep also it's it's
like one of the most interesting parts
of yeah remembering is like i didn't
fall asleep
um so all of this plays
really deeply into this process of like
what do you want to do with your
intention of microdosing and the
intention of microdosing
i don't know um
people's exact personal journeys and
what their intentions are in the in the
process but generally speaking whether
you consciously say it or not it's to
dissolve separation conditioning
yeah
i have to say like the way you described
it right now
this analogy to the mycelium
it clicked for me right now for the
first time
like i heard it before but now i i see
how you mean it i think and let me like
maybe you rephrase it so you you can uh
reflect on that
so before
realizing
the oneness of reality it feels like
there is a
a conscious perceiver that's going on
here and the conscious perceiver going
on over there so here is called lauret
over there is called atlas and all the
other people in our lives
but then when you realize it is more
about the exchange
than about the perception because there
is no
separate perceiver from what is already
like experienced
then it's kind of like what you said the
mycelium the mycelium is more about the
sharing of nutrients
in our case of experiences of concepts
of understanding of feelings emotions
so it's more about what is going on on
the
level of
sharing
this experience then it is about
me perceiving something you perceiving
something yes yes very well said like in
in math um
one of the most important
ways of visualizing this as well it's
been talked about for a while is that
everything's about the relationships
so when you look at something like this
network theory with all these with all
these nodes and with all of the little
lines between the nodes that um
the data that is exchanged in
consciousness with itself is why we do
this yes the information and the energy
that is exchanged
but within um ourselves and between
ourselves is
um
is the way that this comprehends itself
it's the way that it dances with itself
um
so another way of saying like what you
were indicating is that
being the mycelium means that you are
everybody and everything that's
happening between everybody
um
and you are another way of thinking
about it is like
dissolving all of the barriers
completely between
all of the different people as well as
all of the different um animals and all
the different creatures all that and
being the entire planet being the entire
soul being the entire galaxy the whole
universe being that being that like
being like
the so the earth and the solar system
that is here and the earth and the solar
system on the other side it's
you it's still you over there undergoing
a dance it's still you over there going
to dance
and and then you also see that it's like
an entire comprehensive like the
mycelium extend itself beyond the earth
to the whole universe
and that's all doing the comprehension
it's all doing the information um
and energy exchange doing work
um reality as information and energy
doing work
and so to to get this shift you have to
again it's about this decreasing if
you're not decreasing your separation
conditioning if your direct experience
from micro dosing is and in your
integration afterward if it's not
um
like you feeling
less separation conditioning less um
like sadness and anger and unhappiness
and suffering um
then
something's happening in the mix where
your your intention isn't set for the
awakening um but when your intention is
set for awakening then you'll notice in
your direct experience less suffering
more happiness less separation more
oneness more peace seeing that
everywhere being that um yeah
that's the core for me
yeah that reminded me of
something that i learned from rupert's
beer
i love him it's
i think one of the most clear teachings
or teachers
out there and
his emphasis is always
[Music]
on
if you want an answer
and you look for some conceptualization
of how to
explain what is experienced
to go back to experience
because
all that is can be ever known is here in
the experience available and when you
just mentioned that
you see the whole
universe everything
as one
it must be
recognized here
not in concept not in rational
understanding it's
you see that here right now
and one example of how this unfolds is
my very direct experience if i speak
from that right now
there is no difference between me
listening to you speaking
and me listening to
laura speaking
it is all one unfolding
you could say it's unfolding in
consciousness but that would be already
too much there is no consciousness
separate from this one unfolding
and
in there as you just
emphasized is a sense of growing freedom
or from that comes a sense of growing
freedom
because it is only the sense of being a
restricted self
that is then
creating the feeling of limitation
through having an illusory difference
between it and something else perfect
but when you
and for me and also
what rupert spirit says
this can really be seen all indirect
experience
and
it is important to say what you or
emphasize what you also just said is
if your intention is right
that you want to recognize this
then your experience will give you the
give you all that is necessary in order
to recognize it yes yes because you are
the stylist you are the painter you are
god you are the creator and so you with
your will with your choice you determine
your reality and so if at the top of
your
desire list
is awakening then you will
manifest more and more of
the
direct experience of you awakening
if your top of your desire list is
trying to decrease your separation
conditioning through substances and
through relationships through material
possessions um you will
you'll run into a wall repeatedly
um and you'll wonder
why
is this why am i experiencing like uh oh
well while i was you know orgasming or
having sex or whatever that um oh like
i i felt you know my sense of self was
wasn't there the people don't know those
those words and so they just call it
like
um sex or orgasm or love or whatever
even though it's a really perverted um
form of of when they use the word love
but
that that's basically what they're going
for and so um they're going for the the
slipping away of the self but they don't
know that that's the case and so the
most simple way to slip away of the self
is to recognize that i'm god i am the
stylist i am the painter and i may as
well put awakening at the top of my um
of my um
desire list for
um
for being and then in that process what
will manifest for me is for example it
will manifest um content like this it
will manifest um
a connection to a micro dosing um
connection um or a
um
[Music]
you know you'll stumble across ramana
maharshi and you'll start inquiring into
who am i you'll
you'll um
you'll maybe run into
um
one of the um like bentino's meditation
mastery retreat and you'll learn
concentration and meditation and
realization integration so there's um
if you if you put it at the top of your
desire list it'll happen um if you have
it in like rank number 10
in your desires is truth and awakening
then you see where that's going to go
so
yeah
how do you
combine the view
from the
human
where
free will
seems to be limited
where you cannot
decide what is happening in society at
large where
you are
subject to certain things in your
environment that seemingly
are not under your control
with the realization that you are the
one and that you are creating everything
out of your own love
for existence
how did you like
how
how do these two
viewpoints go together
and give me the two viewpoints again
so from our perspective from the human
perspective it seems
what we can decide with our free will is
very limited
and on the other hand when you have the
realization of oneness
it is clear that still everything is
coming from you but not from the human
so where is like the
where is the all encompassing free will
where is that
is that originated somewhere or
how would you describe it let's see if i
understood the question um
yeah so for me the way that i see it is
that
intelligent infinity
creates
first
awareness it creates a will it creates
choice
um it creates the ability to perceive
the ability to know its creation and
then it creates love and light
and so everything's composed of
awareness love and light
and you can think about it like the
electromagnetic dance that everything is
subatomically is that love and light and
awareness dancing with itself playing
with itself
so again information and energy you
can't go any you can't take reality down
any further than information and energy
you just can't and so that's what
awareness love light is
um
now
in terms of the human the human starts
with how i see it it starts with frozen
will it starts with subconscious
unconscious patterns habits that are
more primal that are more animalistic
now this doesn't mean that there's not
you're not going to find the
um you're not going to find the
occasional sage from uh you know ten
thousand or even a hundred thousand
years ago you might you might find an
occasional sage back then um but
um
so generally we're we
in a pattern of becoming self-aware
and then um
so intelligent infinity becomes
self-aware through this veil is fail and
then
um
in that process it unfreezes more and
more of its will and choice from its
conditioning and its patterns around
separation
um and ego and personal bubbles
um
and it shifts more and more towards um
having like air-like will so it like it
feels more and more of its stylus like
basically right now
only by being like silent and still
can i like really feel the stylus
like really clearly
and that's also what's meant by you know
nirvana the complete cessation of all
movement that you feel
that that you that you are that that you
are that absolute permanent changeless
reality that is what gives rise to
endless change to infinite creation but
so when you're still when you're totally
still like right now we're using words
and we're exchanging words but when
you're super still when you're super
silent
you can feel the air like stylus you can
feel that you have this will and choice
to whatever you want next whatever you
want next whatever you desire next um
but if you're reactive and if you're
moving at a pace of in taking a stimuli
and subconsciously or unconsciously
getting triggered and then
moving in that behavior pattern more of
your will is frozen you're not conscious
you're not awake to the stylist the
air-like stylist
so
that's one way to to put that um but
again it's really important that the
absolute and the human
become transcended like the the
distinction between the two becomes
transcended um so even
um
a creature
that or you know a human that is still
very frozen free will um is the same as
um the sage that is um
solely meditating on god all day
um
okay so would you say that
you could express this also as a
cutting away of the
of the drive you you could say you know
from our perspective it seems like
they're coming from the past
so our conditionings that are
usually in our
like
for the regular like let's say normie
they are driving our behavior
and in that sense or to the degree that
we have these
fixed concepts of how
reality is going to behave in that sense
or to that degree we are unfree yes and
on the flip side to the degree that we
can
remain present
in the presence
of
what is
there is less and less conditioning yeah
and in that falling away of conditioning
arises
the freedom
for it to unfold
in an infinite
or as a infinite possibility
yeah that's yeah that's what it would
feel like
but then at the same time
it is in the presence that it seems to
be free
no in the presence it is free and from
the perspective of
putting that presence into
time closing it
between past and future
that it seems unfree
yeah so for me in my perception it's
mainly
the concept of time
that
yeah liberate yourself from that and and
you and you'll um
be
like that's probably one of the biggest
um conditionings is time yeah yeah yeah
destroy that um with love light and um
and you're so much freer time
time is um one of the biggest ones along
with separation time is one of the
biggest ones yeah did you do any per
specific um
meditations contemplations in order to
dissolve this
felt sense of solidity
in the concept of time or the concept of
time well well yeah so
i would say that for for the vast
majority of awakening um like if you
would to pair micro dosing um i would
pair it with self inquiry um
you can also pair it with um just
classic concentration and meditation
but i actually think that self inquiry
can basically take you all the way i
don't even necessarily think that you
need a micro dosing i think self inquiry
can basically take you all the way to
awakening
so for example with time so basically
you can use the intellect to go beyond
the intellect in a sense you can use
um like rationality and logic um to
kind of grok
your nature your true nature you can
grok infinity um
so like one of the most simple ways to
do that would be to like recognize
yourself like this is like you can just
jump straight there you don't
necessarily need to like like
investigate time like from like
kindergarten to fifth grade to ninth
grade to college like like you can go
straight there by just by just doing uh
um
like you know you see yourself as um
like the grand theft auto character
and instead of identifying with the
grand theft auto character
you should be
the xbox or the playstation that is
playing infinite games
um and so then you see oh [ __ ] well i'm
not just a character my identity is
actually the very fabric of existence of
eternity or infinity itself like that's
my identity and then you sort of
liberate yourself from the time trap
faster but like if you do want to take
it a little more gradually for people
that are that are listening um
i've made a good amount of content on
this but like one of the most simple
ways is to just recognize how much of an
illusion all of the symbols are on a
clock
like the symbols on the clock itself are
just a bunch of squiggly lines that are
representative of how we measure the
earth spinning
that's it the earth eating on its axis
is one earth day and then we label that
with little squiggly lines and another
one is that
you take like the earth that orbits the
sun every
365.25 days and you're like well that's
some [ __ ] arbitrary ass number like
one year is
365.25 days it's just arbitrary
numbering um to represent something
useful for us
so that we can you know more easily you
know you and i can meet up for this show
at a specific time and it works in that
sense but so if you sort of like for
generality to like liberate yourself
more and more from what was like another
one is you know biological impermanence
is another one like oh [ __ ] like i'm
this impermanent biological creature and
because of that i'm locked into
believing that i'm the body and
and um you have to like the nettie
nettie method or the not this not that
method of declining the body and
declining the thinking mind
so that you can then recognize yourself
capital s god infinity
and then you can include the body and
the thinking mind you can include it
after you can see god as the body and
you can see god as the thoughts totally
and you can radically love and accept
them as they are but you can't start at
impermanence you have to start at
seeking permanence seeking what is
infinite seeking what your truest nature
is and then recognizing that ah that
pure potentiality which is my truest
nature is actualizing itself as these
seemingly different fireworks in a dance
with itself and then i will eternally be
doing this and then that's where you
liberate yourself from the impermanence
and then you can include the
impermanence yeah
that's so great
that just got me thinking about how this
unfolded very practically in
my meditation sessions and maybe if i
describe this this may help someone so
let me just
say how how i very directly
worked on dissolving the sense of being
something happening in time
um
nice
we we all know when we meditate and we
start we um usually most people start on
with concentrating on the breath
and then you sit there and you think
okay i'm breathing i'm breathing in
i'm breathing out and you let that be
your anchor
but then
when you
are aware of your breath
you can also become aware that that is
not the only thing that you are aware of
right now
you are also aware of your concept of
breathing
and that is happening or that is
creating your sense of time
if we like let's say only look at the
breath and we can really
crowd out all other other thoughts
then in that moment of really being only
with the breath our idea of that we are
breathing is creating time
and
you can see that for yourself when you
are
separating the two
and you are only aware of what is
happening really right now that is maybe
a sensation that you would call
breathing in
but in that moment you thinking that it
is part of a breath that has been
followed by something
breathing out and it was previously you
were breathing in
that is
how in this very moment you create and
in every moment you create a sense of
time
and when you can sort these two out like
your concepts about what is happening
right now from
the flow of experience
then you are you are stepping outside of
time and you see that
you cannot create time outside of this
presence
because every time you do that it arises
as a thought
it arises as a concept as a context for
what you are experiencing
nice yeah and
for me i just had to look at this over
and over and over again to like finally
see very clearly that oh these are
actually two different things
because when you just start meditating
it seems like one thing
it seems like your breath is
what it is but there is actually
the experience and the concept that are
so entangled that it's not easy to
to see at first
yeah and
you can extend that even further
to
not only time but just go even take it
all the way um again much of this show
is
about taking it all the way um as
efficiently as possible
um and
just take your name
all the way like your name is just the
concept
um
so funny that you say that yeah i i just
did this today um
because in the past i often like
repeated my name over and over again
and back then it felt strange because
there was something there was somehow a
story connected to my name and it felt
weird to repeat my name over and over
again because then it was somehow no
longer
there was there was no longer this story
with the name if you repeat it often but
today when i did that there was no more
story no more
it didn't arise anymore i don't know how
to describe it but
yeah yeah and so you take
the
two three four five six seven symbols
that are strung together for your name
and the five symbols strung together for
my name and you just deconstruct it and
then you're like oh [ __ ] it's just a
bunch of squiggly lines strung together
as symbols that then we use these vocal
vibrations to get this
this individuation's attention
um and then you recognize that your
entire life like we talked about has
been self-referential it's been
self-reinforcing self-simulating um
and that you liberate yourself from that
um
that construction project that you've
been doing your whole life of separation
conditioning and this little five symbol
seven symbol strung together name
and then you dissolve into being the one
and you which you've been the whole time
but you've yeah and so then the the
other side to this is that if you put a
name like we call the universe the
universe you know we put a name to the
whole thing right we put a name to it
um
and
like if you called um
this if you called this universe um
like
uh let's say 78
and then you call
um
[Music]
you just you gave it a name you gave
this a name that you can then
deconstruct again you can deconstruct 78
you can also deconstruct the universe
the word itself with strung together
symbols
and all that's left is just the very
fact that we are just that i am just
that this is um
is just what's left and it's not as
um
yeah and that and that's the thing is
like we can use all these symbols and we
can talk we can do this symbol exchange
with vibration and whatnot and it's it's
good and i've been doing it
784
um of these
um
shows and
um you know i guess one thing that i'm
really
you know feeling like more and more
after like four plus years of of doing
this
um
is that like
it's just so truth is beyond the vocal
vibrations and
it's um
so that's why like you know i've been
messaged a lot the last couple of
months about you know like well what's
up with content and stuff like that
and um well
it just feels like i am truth more than
i've ever been before and so now it's
sort of about like honing in on it so
much so clearly so precisely that
basically everything that i you know
speak or do or am or be
um moving forward will just be even more
precisely it um
and so that's you know that's one of the
things to consider as you micro dose
like don't run off right away and tell
everybody about your experience because
you're gonna get a lot of people that
tell you that you deserve to be in a
mental hospital or that you um
um and
or like your parents will
put you on pharmaceuticals or something
you know there's there's a bunch of
[ __ ] up things that um still happen in
the modern day like if you if you have
an experience of the isness and then you
go everything is one and you start you
know telling everybody that you're gonna
get slapped um and so it's
it's it's something to remember along
the journey is to basically take your
realizations
and find the right people to talk to
them about and it it's going to be hard
because it's still not that much of the
planet is super open to talking about
micro dosing and awakening on a
consistent basis
but
finding that community where you can
openly share about your microdosing
experience or about your realizations or
about when you're reading the law of one
and you're studying intelligent infinity
or whatever
that
you have people that you can talk to it
about that can then reflect you where
you may still have some separation
conditioning because they've already
went through those patterns before so
you can accelerate the depletion of your
separation conditioning from 100 or from
90 or wherever you're at to
20 or below
just by finding a really good as in
buddhism the triple gem you have sangha
you need the community you need this
aspect to it as well it's not just the
buddha it's not just the awakening it's
not just the teachings the dharma the
path but it's also the sangha it's the
community it's this lineage it's the all
of the people all of the
antigens all of the direct path
teachings all of the um
shift from um a sleeping to awakening in
the rapid
rapidization of that process
it's your best friend and so find the
other people find the others there are
no others it's hilarious but find them
the ones that
do
uh know this and uh surround yourself
with them as fast as possible
along the way
yeah that mirrors my experience i also
in the beginning
was more eager to talk about my
experiences and insights to people
and over the last years i have refrained
from doing that because
it is not
communicate communicatable to people who
have
no experience of it at all who have no
idea of what you are doing there um
if they are open and if people approach
me that and say
hey i i feel like there's
you have something there and i'm
interested in that
then i i try to find out where they are
at and how can i how i can speak to them
and what
can fall on
fruitful ground
um
but yeah in general as you said it's
not possible to communicate it
and so the sangha where you are with
other people
who just are there you can just be in
silence and it's the most beautiful
communication
because if you are truly at the level
with someone yes
then
yes then you say one word and it's
enough or you don't even say anything
exactly because you're vibrating at the
frequency of god
in most like simple terms you're
vibrating at the frequency of god or
you're vibrating at the frequency of the
one or you're vibrating at the frequency
of love light awareness of the is-ness
that it all is
without separation conditioning you're
vibrating without separation
conditioning um
and so
so take
um
your time in sangha or take your time in
silence like we talked about where
you just pause and you're just
still
and you feel yourself as the stylist as
the painter as that paintbrush
with unlimited
will and potential to express yourself
however you see fit
and take that
and just recognize it
more and more every single day more and
more
you're with somebody ah take a moment
and just recognize in that moment that
you're the one talking to itself with
this other person
it just yeah more and more every day
every day you know bentino talks about
it as two to five seconds
every single day more and more you know
and zog chen one of the most common
teachings is just recognize empty
cognizance over and over again
over and over recognize empty cognizance
empty cognizant
this is empty
cognizance
talking to itself
and one
talking to yourself at a certain point i
feel it becomes
more like an instrumental song
whereas before you try to
intellectualize and extract something
from the teachings nice the more you
listen to it it becomes more like
the end in itself like a song that has
no words
nice
nice that's what it feels like and when
you
at a certain point read books or hear
teachers or be with them
it's more
[Music]
what is not said in the words it's more
what
how the words are said or
that they are there at all you could
also say
and in in a similar way
i i just this weekend was
on a trip to berlin
for a 30th birthday of a friend of mine
and
you know these parties where you are
involved in a lot of small talk you
and you approach all of these people
not from the mind but from the heart
yeah and you
allow them
to just be as an expression of
consciousness
then you connect to them much deeper and
i found
fascinating
people that
kind of were able to pick that up
not many most of them were still a lot
of them were consumed in their stories
but a few
and those were all women who were like
more attuned to this
heart-centered
openness
of consciousness and they they quickly
like
connected to that i could feel it and it
goes
you communicate then just on a different
level it's not about the words so much
anymore and you are
connected
in consciousness in the heart and it is
beautiful to experience this flow of
communication through the heart and not
through the mind
yep
yep
and ramana
and many other mystics i've talked about
just as soon as um
as soon as you really have this anchored
um there will come a time when you just
forget everything that you've ever
learned and
that's some [ __ ] insane [ __ ] it's
basically like um
yeah it's basically like you know
bentino had an exercise that he gave um
the no limits
um community
where he basically said um you know
destroy all of your memory
um period like let go of all of your
memories of that you've ever had ever
like and that's like the most
fundamental like emptying exercise you
can imagine
um
and when you're that empty
everything's just
a hyper-fast refresh rate because
nothing is triggering your conditioning
nothing's triggering any memories
um
nothing's triggering any ways that
you've previously perceived reality
everything is always fresh and new and
infant-like
how would you do that
well here's silence i'm saying like
silence and stillness is how to do it
because like
like like a really simple one is
somebody will be like
republican
and then all of a sudden you'll have
this [ __ ] big word cloud pop up about
republicans and all your thoughts about
them or like democrat
the big word cloud pops up or africa
although
china
the word cloud pops up mom
word cloud pops up money
word cloud pops up with all of your
thoughts about that
and instead
watch how magical it is when somebody
says money and it's just five symbols
strung together into a vibration and you
just have no reference point to what
that is
and it's just you let go of it the
moment it stops the word
yeah it basically dissolves into
emptiness is one of the ways to say it
yeah yes
how would one do that with visual
objects because for example i tried to
like tune into what you just said with
the with the guitar that's standing
there behind the camera and
i see the guitar and it's not just
the shape and the color
i know it's just that in the experience
but when i see this guitar there are
also
kind of as a context
subconsciously vibrating all my memories
of it
and
it's the same for when other people that
you have some shared experience and past
history with when they appear in your
life
you i feel at least you cannot see them
as just
a fresh new experience
and there is this path and your memory
always
kind of vibrating in that experience how
would one do that in this case yeah yeah
so you're not um
making it
non-recallable
so it's still recallable
yeah but you're completely free
so when the guitar appears
you don't have the triggers come up of
all these memories playing guitar the
things that i still want to do with the
guitar blah blah blah instead what
happens is the guitar appears it
disappears
and then what you do from a fresh place
is then you with your stylus
you create whatever reality you want
with that guitar if you want to go and
pick it up and play you will
if you don't want to you won't
if you want to
if you want to play the piano you will
it's just it just becomes um
like when somebody says the word mom
like instead of have or dad instead of
having the word cloud about mom or dad
come up which is um i like these things
about my parents i don't like these
things about my parents
blah blah blah the whole stories the
whole narratives instead what you do is
you just see the concept appear and
disappear
and just dissolve and then from a free
place rather than a triggered place from
a free place then you can cut
as whatever you wish like ah yeah moms
yeah cool yeah dads cool you know
whatever from a free spontaneous place
that doesn't have any conditioning
unraveled within it and this is another
thing that micro dosing will show you
and i know we wanted to talk about um a
little bit about lsd and 5mu dmt as well
and the differences and whatnot but
we kind of actually talked about that a
little bit when we were doing the
mountain analogy because in essence
generally
magic mushrooms and lsd will take you on
the gondola ride depending on the dosage
again this 3000 meter mountain that so
on lower dosages they'll take you less
up the mountain on higher dosages
they'll take you all the way but they'll
take you all the way on the gondola ride
and then back down over a longer period
of time whereas 5mu dmt is like the much
faster gondola ride super fast
and it also like we're talking like the
difference is maybe 30 minutes 5mu dmt
versus 6 to 8 hours magic mushrooms or
lsd
and so
we're also talking about the rapid the
repeat
the rapidness of the dissolution of the
ego structure so that's what we mean by
that mountaintop and so
and again we talked about integration as
well being so critical here like you
have to integrate what you're seeing at
the top of the mountain in your
day-to-day experience
otherwise
the intention of awakening is not
present the whole intention of awakening
is to integrate oneness into direct
daily experience
it doesn't get more simple than that
yeah yes
the
um
itself i have felt this
can
still be
very different in content
the earlier
very deep mushroom experiences of mine
they have been
very chaotic
there was no sen no reference point no
sense of
any recognition of what was happening
there was no
for example um
maybe this can give like a feeling of
how
insane such an experience can be is
i was standing in my room and i felt in
my throat this sense of thirst
there was just this sensation and i was
aware of it but
there was no
ability
to conceptualize this sensation at all
so
while i was seeing my bottle of water
there in the room
i wasn't able to make any connection at
all between
i have to drink water
for this feeling
to go away
like even the idea of water
wasn't there i was standing in my room
and i was pouring the bottle on the
ground
you know
something you wouldn't do because
such an experience on mushrooms
especially they can show you
a lot of individual
conditions fears you have
the fear of going insane
right you you are conditioned to believe
that sanity is something good and
insanity is something bad
and you fear insanity a lot and you
that's what's keeping you
thinking in the ways
that you do
and so different compounds can face
can put you face to face with different
conditionings and fears
yes that's my experience
yeah and and based on the strains based
on the dosages um they will unravel
conditionings absolutely and they will
be different flavors we also talked
about that a little bit um but they're
gonna be different flavors um again the
reason why i highly recommended magic
mushrooms is because it's the most in my
opinion just the most
decentralizing or universalizing in the
most kind of like soft gentle loving way
in my opinion
and
um
have you tried 2cb
uh i haven't yet no 2cb
okay um i haven't had like a major trip
on it but the
micro dosing experiences they were
incredibly promising i would say um
i the
the vibe they had i feel
is very loving it's they say also it's a
combination of um
mdma and lsd
in its effect
and so i feel i want to research that
chemical more just to
feel more comfortable recommending it to
people
because it doesn't have the downsides of
it has no tolerance
you build up no tolerance to it and it
it leaves the part
to reason about your experience intact
so
oh interesting yeah you don't get that
mindfuck component that you can get on
mushrooms oh you totally mind [ __ ]
totally yeah you can't wait one reason
while it's going on at the higher
dosages you're surrendered like you said
it's surrendered yeah
yeah
in that sense 2cb is more
more um
i think it's a better entrance
psychedelic for people who have very
deep fears about losing their minds
about going insane because it somehow
leaves that ability to reason about what
you experience right now in tech and
that is
i find very fascinating so i want to
look into it a lot more in the future
yeah while you were
while you were sharing i just started
kind of like researching it a little bit
more
yeah it comes in this uh
i also have like in this powder form and
you
um
you can just also ingest it like lsd
you can snort it or even plug it but um
it's
it's a very
very gentle experience and because it's
in this
mdma-like it has this
um what said it was the english name
this um empathogenic quality to it i
feel it's very
very friendly experience and you can
surrender much easier to the insights
you have because it feels so loving
cool
cool
yeah
it's really interesting
um
i think it's worldwide it's still um
or not maybe not worldwide but yeah
there are
it's not legal in most countries
but it's a very interesting
substance
cool bro
i mean you are probably also aware of
this uh channel
actualize.org for sure leo yeah leo he
is he had a trip report
maybe three years ago or something like
that and it is a very very um
yeah very interesting trip
for sure and um
[Music]
anyone who is watching it can recommend
there is interest in that substance to
check that uh trip report out
nice
nice yeah
i'm feeling
i'm feeling like anything yeah yeah yeah
i'm feeling like intention is
like feeling like it's good like in
terms of like coming to a close do you
feel like there are other things that
you want to um discuss
no i think we have pretty much covered
a lot of ground
i mean
it is definitely not all
um we didn't say everything about
psychedelics it's the most
complex topic there is probably out
there so
unravels the ego separation conditioning
and how it then
catalyzes awakening like that's a very
um we did a good job covering that as
the essence of
which
which is the point like there's no other
point to do anti-agents except to
unravel your own separation conditioning
so that you can awaken like in terms of
truth truth like pursuing truth like
otherwise you're just pursuing an
experience which is
still trying to dissolve separation
conditioning and feel truth anyway yeah
yeah yeah it's trying that but you have
to combine it with your intention to
make it
work
really well and that is also
why many people can take things like
lsd or 2cb in a party setting and don't
get any spiritual insights out of it
the intention is just not there and so
whenever you go
into a trip
know that how you approach it from a
mental set point is very important
and also yeah
all the
safety concerns
are don't just go blindly into like a
high dose i think what we recommended
here in this
talk is very important to start low it's
always better recommendation than than
to say
start with a heroic dose
i think that's
irresponsible so
yeah
i'm also going to put in the bio um the
healing hustlers um so it's two of my
closest friends they're um producing
some of the absolute best
um
magic mushrooms in
the united states and um i'll put the
link in the bio below and people can
buy directly from them
so for people that want
and i know they ship all across the u.s
and i think they're
they can ship potentially across
maybe internationally so
yeah so i'll put the link in the bio
below for you guys if you do want to try
a micro dose like a half gram or a full
gram or if you've already um if you want
to go 3 000 meters up your little heroic
dose
so
but remember to combine it with the
self-inquiry and with meditation
contemplation of other things that we
were talking about here
um
and
and yeah make sure you're doing this
intelligently with um with well um
[Music]
educated um people with well-educated
people with um
um also with with the smart environments
like your ambiance is intentionality
like we've been talking about so many
times
your intention being for awakening that
in itself will create such a good
experience for you um such good insight
and realization for you um
so
yeah yeah uh one thing i would like to
mention is um
if you go
with psychedelics as you mentioned
before you don't have to do them you
could reach these insights
maybe it takes longer but you can reach
them through
self-inquiry meditation alone but if you
choose to go with psychedelics be aware
that there is the possibility of
having so many
great insights that you are neglecting
your
dualistic life
because we all have to like work earn
money that's still
all not going away when you have deep
mystical experiences and so having
an experience a mystical experience
from the place of having your life in
order
feels much better than
starting from chaos chaos
so
i would have advised people if they
don't go the slow and steady meditation
routine for which you need to have
your life in order in order for that to
work long term
then be careful not to like overdo it
too quickly and neglect because it tends
to cause people to neglect their um
[Music]
other responsibilities in life and at
the end there is only
this it is to be enjoyed and so live
your best life
whether you take psychedelics or not
beautiful brother
yeah
yeah i think
that was a great conversation
me too bro and also everyone can check
out um lauritza's youtube channel um
it's conscious development the link is
in the bio below also um so check it out
go and watch his content
he's uploading quite frequently
and he's got a lot of great content on
there and
go and support him subscribe
like his content share his channel
um with other people
and also same thing goes for
our video as well like uh like the video
um helps the algorithm like it subscribe
to the channel if you haven't yet
comment below with your thoughts on the
video we'd love to hear from you
and share the video with other people
that you feel like this would positively
benefit especially around micro dosing
and awakening and what that process is
like and what it is actually all about
and
um thanks brother what a great yeah
thank you a lot for having me like for
for this opportunity really enjoyed it
yeah great
okay
nice thanks everyone for tuning in we
love you very much you and i will stick
in the studio i'll just end the stream
okay
yes
goodbye
see you
great